i want to get people's perspective on
this story this story is kind of awesome
but it definitely creeps me out a little
bit yeah this is a little creepy it's a
little creepy and we're talking about
jeff
bezos or as you like to call him jeff
bezos bezos demi umbeso which is a kiss
nobody talks about that his name is
basically kiss it's because of the z
dude the z throws everybody else i get
it his newest investment and how jeff
bezos is planning to bet on longevity
and living forever also by the way for a
miami guy the least miami guy from miami
i've ever met
like it's i i want him to be so much
more pitbull than he is he's just he's
like the anti-people yeah he really is
he's like dolly
wait so they say it again what's golly
it's actually he's probably like dollar
that's exactly what he got that loot
dollar he got that loot he went to
palmetto high school i think that's like
right near where you grew up yeah man
miami i was on the north side of miami
how was different are we yeah
my uh freshman year college girlfriend
was the valedictorian at palmetto oh wow
and then she smarted up she's like what
the hell am i doing with this guy he's
broke his [ __ ]
and now she's doing all right but anyway
i know that so are you sauce you're
doing all right i'm doing okay now doing
okay not as a freshman in college i was
not doing so hot
anyway so jeff bezos is basically saying
i'm investing and living forever man i
want to live forever fame
i want to live forever do you even know
that so i don't understand
wow paul you know that song i do sing it
fame
i want to live forever i mean he really
is a stale person huh
i wish we had a camera on paul right now
you see his stupid mustache you want to
rip it off oh that's discount dom over
there discount dammamato whatever his
name is good money for the stash yeah
that's right anyway so basically a sauce
there's a noble winner shenya yamanaka
who discovered a reprogramming and this
biologist mixed human cells into monkey
embryos and they're trying to make
people live longer that's what this
article is so basically
you know peter thiel once family said
death is a problem that can be solved
what a creepy
what a creepy thought sentence yeah
death is a problem that can be solved
well if there's any has anyone ever
lived forever anyone
i don't think so so but let me just
research yeah do something there's a
research right there so the world's
richest man by the way is 57 years young
he threw more money behind an obsession
to become among the billionaires
on a quest to defeat
aging so
bezos horse race is
horse in the race not horse races horse
in the race is something called altos
labs altos labs that basically means
tall labs
in spanish thank you i went there kind
of a promising young startup trying to
reverse aging by reprogramming human
cells
okay
so it's a banking it's banking on
biological reprogramming which just
sounds weird to even talk about
biological reprogramming technology that
rejuvenates cells in a lab which experts
think could eventually help revitalize
entire bodies not bad
a concept this is this is how much rich
guys hate competition they're like i
want to take out people that can live
longer than yeah it's like you're
already the richest space
space yeah internet and now live forever
jeez wow
so the track record of billionaire
funded firms with lofty goals for human
longevity isn't particularly stellar
apparently other people have been trying
to do this but bezos along with peter
thiel previously backed by unity
biotechnology which last last year
failed its first major study cancelled
its main antigens and people people have
trying to do this
it's not working
you know there's they say saying [ __ ]
facelifts
[ __ ] liposuction [ __ ] botox
figure out how to anti-age forever give
me a heart lift yes there it is so um
apparently it's not working out so good
so he's on such a level of wealth
such a level of
richness that he's thinking so freaking
long-term marcelo that he's basically
saying
no death for me you know i say death by
chocolate death by a thousand cuts
that's by nothing that by nothing that's
by nothing no
someone says edgar says speak spanish
that's what's up yeah sauce
i would like to think that i speak uber
spanish
gracias hasta luego and that ladies and
gentlemen is how you raise your lifespan
is by learning another language
that's true
i like how i sometimes i'll pretend that
i don't speak spanish so good if i'm in
a club i'll go up to a
you know a latina and say
bailando
island i think i think the girls might
like that when you get the verbiage
wrong when you get it just a little bit
they think it's cute that you're trying
like oh this cute gringo he wants to
dancing with me
bailando si
vamonos anyway
i think the moral of the story here is
learn another language learn another
language you can't live forever if you
can invest in a company that's going to
rejuvenate yourselves with monkey cells
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken